A wise crack jared incarnate again,
and we've got another wise crack quick
take on this week's rick and morty.
Episode Pickle Rick.
I'm pickle.
I'm here to answer the question,
why does rick turned into a pickle and
yes,
it's partly because Dan Harmon said,
rick is a pickle in a writer's room,
brainstorm harm,
and just goes,
oh,
and then there's the other easy answer
to avoid family therapy,
but if you stick with me,
I'm going to argue that rick's being as
pickle can teach us a lot about freedom,
woken loose,
wise,
crack quick,
take on pickle rick and of course
spoilers ahead,
but first a recap.
Rick,
if you couldn't produce,
has turned himself into a pickle to get
out of family therapy,
but things go awry and he ends up
fighting his way out of a sewer and
later a Russian embassy using a Mech
suit made out of Roche parts and rap.
Lynn's meanwhile,
Beth summer and morty have to go to
family therapy after summer huffed
pottery and animal and morty peed his
pants.
There's a clever parallel between Beth
and rick in this episode,
just as Rick goes to insane lengths to
avoid bearing his emotions and therapy.
Beth is doing her best to stonewall her
school,
appointed therapist,
and maintain her emotional distance.
I think it's possible that you and your
father have a very specific dynamic.
I don't think it's one that rewards
emotion or vulnerability.
I think it may punish them.
I think it's possible that dynamic you
voted your marriage and as infecting
your kids with the tendency to Mr.
Hack their feelings,
both of you to one thing we've noticed
in the season is that there's more
emphasis on serialized arcs.
In the last episode,
Rick is willing to stay in Mad Max land
to avoid dealing with his daughters
divorce.
My Dad has gone through a divorce and I
am not dealing with it in a healthy way
at all.
Now he's literally turned himself into a
pickle to run away from reality,
and Mourdian summers seem increasingly
damaged by their parents' divorce.
I am mad that I can't have enamel
without people assuming it's because my
family is sex.
With
continuation,
we've noticed a few themes that seem to
be slowly developing.
One of which is freedom.
This quote from Dr Wong really sets the
stage for our discussion.
I think it's because the only truly
unapproachable concept for you is that
it's your mind within your control.
You chose to come here.
You chose to talk to belittle my
vocation.
Just as you chose to become a pickle.
Each of us gets to choose.
At first,
Dr Wong's monologue seemed a little
strange.
After all,
how could rick not understand that he's
in control?
He can do anything including turned
himself into a pickle.
The reason anyone would do this,
if they could,
which they can't,
would be because they could,
which they can,
but after digging through my notes on
the ugliest of existential philosophers,
I think Dr Wong's monologue gets us to
something quite insightful.
As we all know,
Rick doesn't believe in God.
There is no god.
Summer.
Got to rip that bandaid off.
Now.
You'll thank me later and for
philosophers,
John Paul Sarte.
Godlessness means we are radically free
to define our own existence,
but we choose to do things based on
social pressures or who we think we're
supposed to be,
and all kinds of other bolts start calls
this acting in bad faith,
but since we're mortal,
there's a fixed amount of choices to
make in our lives.
What sarc calls finitude,
and each of those choices prevents other
choices.
Choosing to be a truck driver means
choosing not to be a teacher.
To deny the importance of our finite
choices is another way to act in bad
faith.
Often we pretend to not have a choice as
west side story puts it.
Hi,
nick.
Sergeant,
crop,
yet gotta understand.
It's just odd bringing upkeep that gets
us out of hand.
Our mothers are junkies are fathers,
all are drunks.
Golly.
Most naturally your punks,
essentially the hopelessness know
they're acting like a bunch of little,
but instead of choosing to be better,
they relinquished their choice and blame
it on their negligent parents.
That's why I'm so bad.
They just can't help themselves.
But what's unique about rick is that he
doesn't deal with finitude.
He deals with infinitude.
My access to infinite timelines
precludes the necessity of attachment.
Rick has to grapple with the exact
opposite of what SARC proposed because
to call back to season one,
there's an infinite number of realities.
Morty rest,
SARC criticizes the person who won't
take responsibility for their choices.
Rick thinks he doesn't have to because
he's already made them and all the
infinite versions of himself.
If Stuart said the human condition was
one,
a finite choices,
well,
rick has transcended that human
condition with science,
but as Dr Wong suggests,
justifying your actions with the
multiverse or your godlike intelligence
isn't a solution because although
intelligence can help you make a
decision,
you still have to make the decision.
The only connection between your
unquestionable intelligence and the
sickness destroying your family is that
everyone in your family,
you included use intelligence to justify
sickness.
Despite the fact that rick is the master
of his universe,
he paradoxically has yet to come to
terms with his own choices.
No matter how many versions of Rick
exists,
nothing can stop the fact that his
choices are uniquely his own.
Because to quote Dr Wong,
the only truly unapproachable concept
for you is that it's your mind within
your control.
In season one,
Rick Straight up tells us how he deals
with the infinite choice in the
multiverse.
What about the reality where Hitler
cured cancer?
Morty,
the answer is don't think about it,
but of course all therapy does this make
you think about things?
So rick turns himself into a pickle to
avoid choice or at least the appearance
of it as a helpless armless pickle.
It's not his fault if he can't make
therapy,
and in that sense Rick's blatant
disregard for his choices,
as SARC would say,
is acting in bad faith.
Speaking of arcs,
this ties nicely into what we talked
about in the last episode between
Jerry's powerlessness,
mortise resentment of him for that very
reason,
and the juxtaposition with Rick as an
all powerful madman,
but I don't respect therapy because I'm
a scientist because I invent
transformed,
create,
destroy for a living.
And when I don't like something about
the world,
I'd change it.
This season is really leading into ideas
of agency and I'm super excited to see
what they come up with next.
There's one last thing worth noting,
but it's probably more of a stretch.
You know,
the common characterization of Freud's
work as everything is a penis.
Well,
I'm convinced someone in their writer's
room probably took this loose connection
between a phallic object in therapy and
who went to little wild with it.
What have you want to hear more about
this?
You want to check out the wise crack
podcast where we're breaking down every
new episode of Rick and Morty Ryan,
Alec and I talk further about all the
intricacies of this awesome episode,
so check us out on itunes or wherever
you get your podcasts.
Thanks a lot for all the support guys.
Thanks for all the recommendations.
Thanks for all the feedback.
Really appreciate it.
See you later.
Yeah.